so yes thank you very much for having us
I'm with the microfiber team and there
has been some talks about microfiber
already in this event which is really
great
all circuit Python so mostly of them are
in the well maker sector or maybe in
educational in the education so I would
like to talk a little bit about how my
group item is already used in industrial
applications where we are involved
directly or we know that it's used so
first of all I give it an overview so is
there someone who has never heard of
Michael Patten before yeah so perfect so
I introduced a little bit how what we
did and where we are now and then I go
and show you a real product that works
with Michael prizes with a general
asleep was allowed to bring here and I
want to share a little bit how we think
Michael Pythian games generate well an
advantage for companies if they use it
in the product development and I'm happy
to answer some question afterwards about
to talk about micro patent in general if
you're interested so let's just go into
it what is micro Python it aims to be a
lean and efficient rewrite of Python so
it's rewritten completely from scratch
it has a lot of it has a compiler
virtual machine a runtime system a
garbage collector so you can compiled to
bytecode a native machine code it
supports an inline assembler and all the
are compilation happens on the chip
which means you don't have to install
anything on your PC everything is
interpreted on the controller so you can
you're all Python programmers so you are
very familiar with the wrapper so you
can use this like if you're doing your
normal Python microfiber is not
completely comparable with Python but we
aim to be as much the same as possible
so this seems all alike a lot of work
which it was the creator of micro Python
Damion George had had the idea in 2013
because you wanted to you
in troubled language too easy control
his hardware devices and he would really
like to have it done with Python so he
thought maybe there would be other
people interested in this so I run a
Kickstarter and I always wanted to run a
Kickstarter because everybody's doing it
so he collected about hundred thousand
pounds for this initial idea so the
community was very into it Michael Palin
was kind of wanted so with these first
initial one hundred thousand pounds the
first better michael Pythian pie bot was
created which you see dancing to the
left so that the first three thousand
pieces of these and since then we have
really come a long way that has happened
a lot my group i this is open source
project on github so everybody is more
than welcome to contribute we have about
six thousand five hundred stars and
ranking in the top 100 of the C C++
projects so yeah it's kind of famous and
so in the UK that was the BBC micro bid
project where in 2016 all the 11 to 12
year olds got a BBC micro bit to where
Michael Pathan can run for teaching
there are already other companies using
micro PI's and to ship their development
parts you might have heard about circuit
Python from Adafruit and there are more
companies like Pi calm or open and B or
do machine vision then very exciting for
us like a really big milestone is that
there's the first micro Python
O'Reilly book coming I program like it's
already out also last year programming
with micro Python and we are ready to
launch the second generation of Pi bots
which I will go into more detail later
in the talk so when I talk to people
about so Christine what do you do for a
living and these are embedded
programmers they say oh yes Python for
microcontrollers last time when I
checked Python was an interpreted
language so this is slow it eats up a
lot of resources and it's not very
energy-efficient yeah well
they are right but let me just say micro
pricing is fast enough for most tasks
and if you look at the development time
when you do or do a redesign of a
product I have the first idea of the
product it's really really fast
so the benefits of scripting languages
you all know them it's easy to learn
them with micro Pisan on your first
initial bot you get an easy working
prototype very quick so even if you just
have to show it off to a customer to get
the first proof-of-concept you can have
this ready in a couple of weeks it's in
accept then maybe you do it with C so
the time to market might get reduced
through this but all these development
boats and IOT things are about is that
it's easy extensible like by a user so
you really want to tweak it your way so
it's easy to do this with a scripting
language instead of maybe with plain see
what's traditional in the embedded
market so luckily there are some some
people who use micro path in the product
development so there's one company that
came across Michael Pathan when they
were searching for lightweight Python
implementation but they didn't want to
have a full Linux system on the device
so they were firstly going with embedded
leaner with an embedded Linux system but
they wanted to get rid of all the blown
shell scripts that they have to use on
it on the device and this company so
they made a bold decision at the time
because micro Python was very young and
two years later they actually are now
500 an amp ere's with an active rebel so
this is quite impressive because they
can they're able to do real-time image
processing now yeah so this is one story
and I'm going to tell you a little bit
more about the different projects I'm
aware of so there is one project this is
still working project they are
approaching us and they are looking into
it and they're very excited and we are
very excited too then there are
prototypes of redesigns from existing
products when the actual products
which end of life and people looking
into it maybe we can do this in a more
efficient way and we using micro Python
and there are really new products like
we have a new idea and we are
approaching is so and the device I
brought here has a successful
certification and it's already in
production so these devices are running
in the field 24/7 like with high real
reliability so I wouldn't really want to
say that there are real products out
there working in the field yeah
so when we talk about my comparison it's
definitely worth like he is the creator
of micro PI's and so it's Jorge robotics
and as he is a background in theoretical
physics and he approached a design by a
more academic and research orientated
point of view instead of just simply I
want to fix this problem and we think
that this is the reason why micro Python
is so successful so the first company I
want to talk about is aqua power
technologies it's a UK company they are
based in the Lake District and they
create innovative machines to generate
power for marine environments so if you
have a look they have really really cool
huge hardware which they put into the
sea it's really amazing and they are
looking into their product the called
the aqua boy and currently it's collect
it's logging and collecting data from
from an excellent major how the waves
are flowing and actually now it's using
MATLAB but they wanted to have it on
their device on the embedded hardware so
they were approaching us so micro Python
team would this be able to do and we
were saying yes and we are very excited
about implementing this in the next
couple of weeks so this is still working
progress but it's coming up then there
is a US company called travesty
consulting he's used my Python for his
product development to make them even
more rapid because he's a he's a
mechanical electrical and software
design
engineer and what he said it's like the
constant battle of finding components
and tools which are easy to use I still
have a professional level there's kind
of a gap some micro PI's and kind of
filled this for me yes so he says as you
can see on the left side this is a an
adapter board which has the same
microcontroller is our PI would
reference pot and he designs his own
little BOTS and plucks it or solders it
on his expansion boards unfortunately
I'm not allowed to say what final
product this will be but this bill is
also used in in a real product in the
end yeah and he said it's so easy to
that he don't really need it needs a
debugger because he already has two
running microcontroller and you don't
have to care about this so you can
really focus on his how can i connect
this sensor how can I get the you are
working or something like this and then
there is a company which the pro driver
brought here they are all they are doing
manufacturing of monitoring the traffic
on highways mainly on highways yeah so
this is this is this is a German company
based in Hamburg and Tristan in the
market they are quite small but they're
quite aggressive and they have the only
working solution that has a real
certification like like the high end
certification in the my sorry yeah so on
the left side you see a traffic
monitoring and classification system
because there are two problems you have
a lot of vehicles and they are all need
to be categorized in some way because if
you want to have new roads you need to
bring reliable data on is there really
so much traffic well I sometimes just
have to go to the Autobahn we just need
to me and I can see it that there's too
much traffic but yes you have to have
the reliable data and then there's
another problem there are a lot of
overload vehicles and you not always see
them as easily as like in the picture
here so they have this
that's called weigh-in-motion so it's
basically you have the road and there
are three lines of sensors which can
measure the weight of the truck so when
you have your race over load truck
coming from the left to the right
it gets categorized in how much does it
actually allow it to weigh and it's
connected to a charge amplifier and they
collect the data in the traffic
monitoring system so this wim T is p32 I
brought with me one of these and
actually I couldn't bring the street and
the sensors implemented under the need
so but this would be really fun like
driving with a with the truck here so I
brought this here with the simulators
they use in the lab because of course it
has to be tested in the first place
before before you actually go to the
trick and spend a lot of money you will
for the drivers and yeah so let's see if
I can show you so the device is all
already running and it's probably at
2:00 so there's an implemented OLED
display which is only for like visually
visualization because most of the time
this is switched off because no one is
actually there and looks at it but it's
really convenient to see that so there
are two lines connected and you get
somewhere
you get the number of the line the way
of the truck and the categorized week
like they categorize different kind of
vehicles in numbers and so the probe
this is all running so very nice but if
we stop this you can see actually that
there is a PI bond some people have used
with the PI board but there's actually a
PI bond running on this device like
literally not a PI bond it's the
microcontroller ship but it's running
microfiber so I hope this gets a little
bit like this is a real-world project
[Music]
sorry
so how micro pride made the difference
obviously it was very obvious because
the controller that has to be used was
in the beginning wasn't actually an f4
which is running on the private as well
and then they improved it to an f7
because they have to do the tag that 232
A to D channels all in like in real time
in a lot in line so they need to realize
the fast real time response and what was
really easy to implement for example
when you have these displays or other
things like the peripherals of the the
things that's on the device which is not
really like a core implement but to get
them connected and put put this this all
together was was really easy with micro
Python so so it's the amazing software
isn't it like this super great
implementation of Damien George yes it
is but let's just say it's also
combination of hardware and software and
how easy it is to plug something in so
this what you can see over here is our
new board new board which is like half
the size of the normal high board and
the idea was to have you probably know
this is P 32 chips which you can buy
everywhere but you still have to solo
them so we we want to really want to
have something that you can with a micro
USB connector already to plug into your
laptop and program it and which you can
really really easy put on an adapter
board and get ready to start programming
so you can really focus on what's your
actual actual problem to solve and not
to program first get the micro
controller running so that you can test
it separately which means you don't have
to worry about if the actual micro
controllers working so yeah the new PI
body it's called it has more
functionality than our PI about one
point it's only two point four grams
that's more power so it's with a better
efficiency
it has it runs an m7 with 2260 megahertz
and 256 K K RAM so it really it's really
low power consumption and it's ready to
use modules but still in the size of
these ESP 30g models you might know so
there's Wi-Fi and a Bluetooth chip
enabled which already ready to use and I
wanted to show off a little bit of the
data compared so the pide 1.1 which is
the original PI watt runs at 168
megahertz which is comparable to doing
120 megahertz on the new PI watt so when
you have them idle it consumes about 80
milliamps and if they run they are at 55
million so this is quite comparable but
the new board can have up to 260 minutes
which is about one point seven five
times faster than than the normal pipe
like the old like the first pi board and
there you have a power consumption from
34 milliamps and it runs at 112 millions
light sleep is 500 microamps and deep
sleep with real-time clock enabled is 10
milliamps and what are quite good
numbers is the downloading data to to
the by private which is 100 milli ampair
milliamps around 800 kilobyte per second
and the upload is 1 megabyte per second
at about 150 40 milliamps so and then of
course there are things micro pieden is
not so good at or cannot do it also if
you have really small microcontrollers
it's best you use just traditional see
it's still a dynamic type language so
you really really have to get your
memory fragment like your memory in
order with the garbage collection so if
you generate too many object objects so
you have to keep that in mind and if you
are going with really really large
projects you might prefer an embedded
Linux system
so to sum up what are the pros and cons
about this
well productivity went up the
traceability because you have a huge
community looking standing behind that
in the open source which they really dig
out problems and this is great because
you rely on that the testability went
fast because you might have already the
running board which you just have to
plug in to your adapter board it's
really easy to port to controller that
has more power for example and the
license licensing was an advantage
basically because MIT license allows you
to use the code but you can really close
what might be your generator like which
generates your profit in the end yeah
and there's quite good support from the
team well not so good might be that
they're increased hardware resources but
all the upcoming microcontrollers show
that we shouldn't be really have a
problem with that but sometimes might be
too expensive and there might be some
lack of develop skills regarding the
scripting languages because today you
usually have secret programmers in the
embedded world so this might be
something which needs to be more
approached because they do what they're
used to but they might not see the
advantage right away so I hope you
enjoyed the talk you can find more
information on micro python.org in our
forum or if you want to support
microbiome project you can buy something
pick something up from the store
obviously or you can write me an email
if you have some feedback so I hope you
enjoyed the talk and I'm happy to have
some questions
Thank You Christy that was really
informative does anyone have any
questions
all right quite a few the examples you
gave were mostly around development
trial small-scale applications can you
see micro Python being used for larger
scale higher budget more critical uses
what sort of thing well I think there we
have the problem Mike replies I'm still
quite young with the five years so
there's no so what happens in ten years
because this is might be the problem way
the bigger companies are still holding a
little bit back maybe so these are all
bolt small companies will see an
advantage in this but yeah I to be
honest well the work with the ISA if
some of you have made heard of this I
see them in satellites obviously at some
point yeah absolutely thank you very
much and I want you to know for someone
who's been dabbling with Arduino and now
needs something a little bit beefy and
something a little bit bigger to work
what sort of platform you suggest to go
I've seen that there is this SP 32
that's it's promising but I wonder well
saying that there are lots of those
around so which is that it would suggest
for someone wants to explore bits of the
embedded words with those newer platform
well yes you might have seen the
official micro Python has parts for the
esp8266 and ESP 32 so they are cool
chips but they are not well if you want
to explore and don't want to spend a lot
of money go with them but if you really
want to put this one in a real
application I would not recommend it
right now I'm not saying that they won't
be there at some point but they still
have too many Hardware bugs but if you
want to explore sure there might good
start with them cheap stuff
but obviously you should buy a PI bond
promoting can you describe the different
sleep modes and what kind of uses they
have the different sleep mode yeah so
yeah when you look into the IOT section
you might have devices with done 99.9%
are in deep sleep and you just sent data
to somewhere in the 0.5 over 0.1 percent
so with the light sleep you can wake up
your microcontroller with an interrupt
and with the deep sleep you have the
real-time clock which needs to be very
accurate to wake it up again so these
are just very first measurements so be
patient I had more we should be having
more very soon but yeah like also like
when you have the Wi-Fi enabled and
disabled and yeah
hi can you tell me whether micro Python
is sort of true real-time or can it does
it run on a real-time operating system
does it come with an operating which
which operating system do you recommend
using it with and can it be
deterministic real-time in terms of the
interrupts if you're trying to build a
controller deterministic real time in
the sense that it could respond quick
you know within it within a guaranteed
time period in the way that micro colas
micro controllers traditionally do yes
so I didn't quite get the question with
the operating system well how do how
does Michael Python work with which
operating system do you use or is it is
it an operating system it's well it's
and of operating system for your micro
controller all right but you don't
really need an A+ or anything in between
on your micro controller - so you just
need to flash the firmware on the micro
controller or do you mean the PC where
you interact with your device like how I
plugged it in and showed you just the
micro just wanted weather so it's so
micro Pythian is all you need on the mic
on the micro controller yes so there's
no eros or other layer in between so you
can flash it right on it and that's
great and and it works with interrupts
and would he say that it was what we
used to call deterministic real-time
which any evident responds kachunk to an
into an interrupt within it oh great
fantastic thank you
you mentioned that you could use some
micro Python with BBC micro Bert can you
use it with Arduino or Raspberry Pi
there is a Raspberry Pi bare-metal port
without it you know I'm not sure to be
honest I don't think so but it runs on
the BBC micros everything are you a
teacher are you using the BBC micro no I
think we can do one last question on
that side maybe anyone I just asking
because we've seen some examples of of
it being used like will the data sound
data science tools how easy is it for
someone like me which I'm mostly in the
data science and a small little bit in
the development side for me to just
start using it in in a real-time use for
example like all connecting it to a
sensor array for any of that use well I
would say it's really easy so if you
want to try this there's some
documentation on our website you just
need to have a board you can buy one
that is already micro patent flashed on
it or you can flash it yourself just see
what they are available so connecting a
sensor like an i2c e or something it's
really easy to set up if you were just
like dipping your feet into something
like very first time so no worries about
that should be very easy straightforward
okay lovely that concludes our session
we have a coffee break from 11 to 11 20
and then we continue from there
Thank You Christine
[Applause]